Digamos que estamos investigando algún tipo de
enfermedad y queremos ver si hay alguna relación
entre que las personas tengan anticuerpos para
esa enfermedad y si son adultos, niños o bebés.
Si no sabes qué son los anticuerpos, pues son
sustancias que nuestro sistema inmune mantiene
a la mano para reconocer a futuras infecciones.
Pero no es un tema necesario para este video,
nos vamos a enfocar en cómo visualizar los
datos para entender si hay alguna relación entre
tener esos anticuerpos y la edad del individuo.
Entonces, digamos que recolectamos datos, ¿ok?,
le hacemos pruebas a 120 adultos, de los cuales
114 tienen anticuerpos y 6 no; también le hacemos
pruebas a 60 niños, y de ellos 54 tienen los
anticuerpos y 6 no; le hacemos pruebas a 20 bebés
y de ellos 8 tienen anticuerpos y 12 no. Podemos
simplemente ver estos datos, pero aún no tenemos
una representación visual de lo que está pasando.
Podemos dar el siguiente paso, que tampoco nos va
a dar una representación visual completa, pero el
siguiente paso es pensar en los porcentajes, eso
nos ayudaría a pensar en la probabilidad de tener
dichos anticuerpos. Si calculamos los porcentajes,
tenemos algo así, por ejemplo: 114 de 120, eso es
el 95%, el 95% de los adultos tienen anticuerpos:
114 / 120 es 95%; y ahora el número de adultos que
no tienen anticuerpos es de 6, es del 5%: 6 / 120;
y podemos hacer eso en cada una de las categorías:
54 / 60 es el 90% y 6 / 60, puedes hacer este
cálculo mentalmente, es el 10%. Podemos hacer lo
mismo también para los bebés: 8 de 20 es el 40%,
mientras que 12 de 20 es el 60%. Esto nos ayuda
bastante, nos ayuda a pensar en cuál es el
porcentaje de adultos que tienen anticuerpos o qué
porcentaje de los bebés o de los niños. Pero si
realmente lo queremos visualizar, podemos ver dos
tipos distintos de visualizaciones. Una se llama
la gráfica de barras segmentadas. Aquí tenemos una
gráfica de barras segmentadas para estos datos.
En una gráfica de barras segmentadas tenemos una
barra para cada una de estas categorías: adultos,
niños y bebés, y estamos haciendo que cada una sea
una categoría, porque creemos que eso tiene algo
que ver con la probabilidad de tener anticuerpos.
Y para cada barra, por ejemplo, para la barra de
los adultos, podemos ver el porcentaje que tiene
anticuerpos y el porcentaje que no los tiene:
el 95% de la barra de adultos está coloreada de
azul, eso quiere decir que sí tienen anticuerpos,
y el 5% está coloreado de rojo; y para los niños
podemos ver que el 90% está coloreado de azul y
el 10% está coloreado de rojo, porque el 10 por
ciento no tiene anticuerpos; y para los bebés
podemos ver que el 40% está coloreado de azul
y el 60% no tiene anticuerpos. Esta gráfica es
muy útil porque nos permite ver que es mucho más
probable que los adultos tengan anticuerpos a que
los niños los tengan, y es muchísimo más probable
que los niños tengan anticuerpos a que los bebés
los tengan. Así es que parece que las gráficas de
barras segmentadas son una buena forma de empezar
a entender la probabilidad de tener anticuerpos.
Aunque también la pudimos haber dibujado de otras
formas; también pudimos haber puesto una barra
para los que sí tienen anticuerpos y otra barra
para los que no tienen anticuerpos, y segmentarlas
con respecto a si son adultos, niños o bebés. Pero
si hiciéramos eso, más bien estaríamos tratando
de entender si el hecho de tener anticuerpos o
no predice si eres un adulto, un niño o un bebé;
aunque a mí me parece que esta configuración tiene
más sentido que si eres un adulto, niño o bebé
nos ayude a predecir si tienes anticuerpos o no.
Sin embargo, sí se está perdiendo información en
esta gráfica de barras segmentadas, por ejemplo,
se pierde el hecho de que muestreamos más adultos
que niños y muchos más niños que bebés. Una forma
de incorporar esa información en una visualización
es mostrar de cuántas personas era la muestra en cada
una de las categorías, de esa forma estamos
generando una gráfica de mosaicos. Esta es una
gráfica de mosaicos. Una forma de pensar en estas
gráficas de mosaicos es que simplemente tomamos
una gráfica de barras y ajustamos el ancho de cada
una de las barras para que refleje el número de
personas a las que les hicimos pruebas. Como les
hicimos pruebas a 200 personas, entonces podemos
pensar que la longitud de este segmento representa
a 200 personas. Como analizamos a 120 adultos,
el ancho de la primera barra -aunque ahora estamos
en una gráfica de mosaicos, ¿ok?-, pero este ancho
tiene que medir el 60% de todo el ancho, y podemos
ver que así es; y con respecto a los niños:
60 de los 200 participantes son niños, entonces
este ancho de acá tiene que medir 60 entre 200,
es decir, el 30% de la longitud total.
Podemos ver que analizamos muy pocos bebés,
analizamos a 20 bebés, que son estos 20 de
acá, aquí tenemos representados a los 20
bebés que analizamos. La razón por la que esta
gráfica de mosaicos transmite más información es
porque transmite la misma información que la
gráfica de barras segmentadas, pero, además,
nos muestra que analizamos a más adultos que
niños y a muchos más niños que bebés; y además
hace que también sea mucho más fácil fijarse en,
por ejemplo, el número total de personas que no
tienen anticuerpos -estos estarían representadas
en esta área roja, por acá-. Con este tipo de
gráficas podemos ver que, aunque analizamos
muy poco a los bebés, los bebés conforman
una muy buena parte de las personas que no tienen
anticuerpos. Pero bueno, aquí vamos a terminar. El
propósito de este video es entender por qué son
útiles las gráficas de barras segmentadas y las
gráficas de mosaicos. En los próximos videos
obtendremos más experiencia analizándolas.